[Musique]
tony hawk est avec nous commençâmes
antonio déjà bonsoir vais me antonio
bonsoir il est dans le truc ça y est il
est dans là il est dans la téloche
on nous l'a beaucoup de gens qui te vous
croyez qu'on croyait qu une rente
annuelle et encore non plus oublier que
c'est l'habitude des notes public
antonio nommé tp suis là non plus il
marque pas j'adore parce qu'il n'ya pas
un micro qui marche donc antonio va
faire le tour de table
et pendant ce temps on va tkip et
inquiète pas on a des micros il ya un
magasin qui est ouvert jusqu'au bas qu
elle est à droite
première à droite sonos neko merci oui
alors vous vous comprenez alors attendez
attendez il paraît qu'il ya que moi qui
ai un micro pour l'instant tout a sauté
ya que moi qui peut parler il n'y a que
mon micro qui marque d'un grade malaisie
a redit jeudi confiant quand même dans
un monde de fous et que cet envoi je
trouve un signal de dictature il ya dix
policiers et quatre plages et gerani
n'est pas d'accord alors dictature tu
dis vraiment n'importequoi lieu mais
c'est pas la première fois moi je pose
aucun problème
jean michel jarre les verts vous
organisations ont besoin d'un homme tué
quelque chose a averti les policiers
dans la journée devait être prêt à
n'importe quelle intervention je vous
parle hélas oui mais veut pas oui
bonsoir ne sont pas équipés rila dollars
c'est totalement délirant ce que je
viens d'entendre
franchement je trouve ça scandaleux on
me dit que quand c'est moi les micros 1
[Musique]
randonnée ils sont comme ça toute la
journée pour pas pourquoi ils se
mettraient en parlera pas le vois pas ce
qui peut choquer sont des polices et ils
sont en armes c'est tout à fait normal
y'a rien de choquant là dessus
n'attendez jean léonard j'arrive s'il
vous plaît j'arrive je serai pas
toujours là antonio jure mois sur la
tête de ses enfants qui tuera pas jeter
les armes en plastique et des enfants ça
je ne regardais comment voulez vous
après que les gens respectent mais
benjamin comment voulez vous que les
gens respectent les choses ne l'entend
pas abouti comment es tu toi brut et
voilà